70 conservative mps have voiced their
anger at the tier system of coverage
restrictions that will replace the
national lockdown
in england next week the prime minister
has been forced to make a number of
concessions
already including offering mps another
vote on it in the new year
well joining us now is the foreign
secretary dominic ram thank you very
much for being
here in the studio there's a real depth
of anger isn't there on the conservative
benches about this new tear system are
you a bit worried you might lose this
fate
well look i think we've got a confident
message that we need to explain and
listen as well
the reality is we want to come out of
national lockdown and stay out of it
there is hope there is light at the end
of the tunnel with the prospect subject
to regulatory approval of the vaccine
being ready to
be in place and distributed by the
spring which will allow real step change
back to life resembling normal the two
things we need between now and then
this tiered approach so that we can
target the the the virus where it's the
the most dangerous we are starting with
a more restrictive approach than
previously with a localized approach
but that allows us to ease up when we're
confident the virus is going down
and stabilized there's a review every
two weeks the second thing is just the
testing
and what we've seen we've had 12 million
people tested
and we've seen in liverpool with the
community-wide testing
at scale done more quickly that really
helps us bear down the virus
those two things are the crucial bridge
to that light at the end of the tunnel
in the spring at the same time though no
one's arguing that there should be any
restrictions
what people are worried about is that
these particular restrictions under the
tier system
are not fair and you can see why people
feel that you know
lancaster city council for example lower
infection rate than
every single one of the london boroughs
but that isn't tier three
and london ends up in tier two how is
that fair well there's five criteria
that we're looking at and that are being
applied
not just for the initial tiering but as
we go through and as i said there's a
review every two weeks
it's the prevalence of the virus the
prevalence uh amidst the
over 60s the testing rate um the
the positivity testing rate the impact
on the nhs
and all of these things need to be
looked at around and so how many just
just just
break that down so you've got five
things how many of those things need to
be
over a certain level level for example
to be put into tier three what what is
the criteria
well it's the five principles and
ultimately it's a it's also a question
of judgment
so the just to give you an example
because i know it and i and i've said
that judgment doesn't sound like it is
really fair
well it's of course it's a balance
between being so prescriptive that
people say it's rigid and you can't take
into account the holistic uh impact in
an area but let me give you an example
one of the things that we realized is
that where you've got low levels
in a particular area but it's surrounded
by others with higher levels and
i think the west midlands is a good
example that dudley in other areas if
you don't
apply on a wider level which is why
we're using the county-wide basis
the same restrictions all that happens
is the virus in those lower level if you
like enclaves goes
up exponentially so just to come back on
that then you've seen that happen in
places like kent for example
where the whole of kent has put into
higher restrictions because of a few
pockets of
high levels what hasn't happened in
london or you've got some boroughs with
really very high infection
rates and yet the whole of london is in
tier two well as i said you've got to
look at the
the five principles and one of the other
things and i know michael gove was
talking about this over the weekend
is just making sure that the nhs and and
that will depend on the
capacity and the pressures in those
local areas is able to cope
but this is about bridging through to a
better place in the spring where again
subject to the regulatory approvals but
we're making good progress we'll be in a
position with the vaccine
we've already secured 355 million doses
of the vaccine we've got a new
uh nadim zaha we're really driving that
area that area of policy forward
um and and i actually think that there
is a more hopeful message
amidst of course uh the fatigue people
feel in the winter months
is it uh correct uh that the government
is thinking about breaking
the regions down into smaller areas so
for example we've seen the kind of as
you say like county-wide or
or sub-region-wide levels of tears
you think about breaking that down into
small error areas that would allow some
people to come out of
the stricter tiers earlier well we'll
have a review every two weeks and of
course there'll be i'm sure debate
this week on it but specifically on that
is that under consideration well we
always
look at all things but the problem is
the one that i mentioned before
that you've got to get the geographic
size sufficiently effective
that you don't find if you like the
smaller enclaves of lower level virus
shooting up because they're not subject
to the restrictions uh in the higher
level areas around them
um mps also want to see a cost benefit
analysis of all this so looking at the
costs of the tier system too
have you done that so first of all a
huge amount of transparency on data both
from the scientists and sage but also
from the ovr this week
what we will do in advance of the vote
uh uh this week is make sure that there
is
analysis of the cost benefits of both
the covid health outcomes the non-coded
health outcomes
economic impact and indeed the social
impact and i've been talking to
colleagues and i think this is a fair
question people want
to make sure it's a rounded judgment
that's taking into account not just the
measures we need to
bear down the virus but the the the
corollary damage that that may then be
taken
particularly on jobs and livelihoods you
talked a bit about the
you know the light at the end of the
tunnel that kind of hope that we have
with the vaccine coming as well and
boris johnson's told mps that
effectively the tier system could end in
nine weeks at the same time there you
know this is a man who
back in march said that we can turn the
tide within 12 weeks he told us in july
that he hoped he could have a
significant return to normality by
christmas i mean i know this is a man
who likes to dish out good news but
don't you need to be a bit realistic
here we do
and i think he is in fairness but the
we've seen the success of the
uh vaccine through the trial process
we're not that there yet we need to make
sure they're safe
but we've got to the stage as i said
where we've secured uh over 350 is not
going to end in nine weeks so is it
does it get real what what the point i
made at the outset sophie
we think by the spring we don't know but
we think we may be in a position then to
move to a whole different world
because the vaccine will have been
distributed to
key workers and the most vulnerable
particularly by age at that point things
can change
the question is how we avoid the virus
getting out of control damaging lives
and livelihoods putting undue pressure
on the nhs during this period so i do
think that this is this feels like an
exit strategy and i do think that with
that comes some cautious grounds for
hope
okay um now of course a big
issue that many people are worried about
is the economy you know i spoke to the
head of uh faulkner masons this week who
said that
a third of uk brands in his view could
disappear by march when we're talking
about you know perhaps
entering this different world do we all
need to think a bit about where we spend
our money this christmas to try and
support british business
i always do that anyway and i think
people do there is a sense of
patriotism as well but i'm not going to
dictate how consumers spend their money
i think people do that automatically
anyway and we do know that
the the economy has taken a big hit
rishi sonek talked about it
in the house of commons this week the
biggest contraction in 300 years
we've got a budget deficit which is
double the peak
of the financial crisis so we've all got
to try and do our bit to help businesses
through what is incredibly tough times
you say there you know you outline the
economic picture which as you say
does feel pretty bleak at the same time
we've got the highest covered death toll
in europe
have we ended up in this position if we
not locked down hard enough to save
lives but look down too hard to save the
economy
i think it will there'll be a time where
we have all of the all-cause mortality
rates and we can look
and compare to other countries i think
the uk's got some specific beaches about
it quite densely populated we've got an
aging population
there's quite a lot of people living
longer but with
co-morbidity and that's been a very
vulnerable target that the virus has
gone for
but at the end of the day i think if you
look for example at where we are with
the vaccine if you look at where we are
with testing 12 million people
have been tested the best testing rate
in europe of course we've
seen bit not quite as good though well
it's a challenge but you know
on the one hand as you've said we'll be
accused of being overly authoritarian if
we go into
uh tough and on the other hand there's
there's we know we've topped 57
000 people who have died tragically as a
result of this awful pandemic and we've
got to get that balance right
but i do think there is a strong story
to tell on vaccines
on testing and light at the end of the
tunnel um just quickly how are you going
to be spending christmas
uh with my uh my folks and
i hope my sister so i just as you say
like
how so three households mixing them and
we're going to follow the rules i guess
you
quite rightly expect um let's move on to
brexit yeah crunch time of course
really important and a few weeks ahead
um
how confident are you that we'll get a
brexit deal do you put the chances at
more than 50
i'm not i've sort of avoided the
percentage
uh betting and forecasting throughout
this but look i do think
uh we're in a reasonable position
there's a deal to be done
if you look really what the outstanding
issues are of course level playing field
but it feels like there's progress
uh towards greater respect for what the
uk position was on fisheries there's a
point of principle
as we leave the eu we're going to be an
independent we've left the
as we leave the transition we are an
independent coastal state
we've got to be able to control our
waters we can talk about transitions and
things like that
and we recognize the impact it has on
other countries around europe but that
principle
comes with sovereignty comes with
leaving not just eu but the transition
period
and and i think the answer is can the eu
accept that point of principle which
comes with us leaving the political club
it feels like you're still a long way
away on fishing
outstanding major bone of contention if
you look at the reports
uk wants british fishermen to have
access to eighty percent of fish caught
in
uk waters the eu thinks it should be 18
that
feels like a big difference but i think
i i think it is a a significant
difference and sophie
does that sound right eighteen percent
control over fish
fish in our own waters that can't be
right do you think that it could
collapse over fishing the deal
i think it's important that the eu
understand the point of principle if
they show the pragmatism the
goodwill and the good faith that in
fairness i think has surrounded the last
leg of the talks and certainly we've
shown in our flexibility i think there's
a deal to be done
um it feels like you're more optimistic
on level playing phil though is there a
landing zone there
i think level playing field um is
something where
we can we accept some of the principles
and we've also got the precedence in
other deals like if you look at
what's been said about global level
playing field standards in the career
deal
with the eu or the canada-style deal and
all we're saying is we ought to adopt
the same precedence that eu has
with other third countries do you think
that there is a landing zone do you
think
there's been progress there i think
there's a landing zone if the eu is as
reasonable as the uk has been
okay that's not quite what i asked but
okay but at the end of the day it
requires both sides to be
a little bit flexible and pragmatic i do
think the economic
two-way advantage of getting this over
the line ought to focus mines
in the last uh last few days is it even
more important because of covered
well in one sense covert i mean i talked
through the damage to the economy the
biggest contraction in 300 years in one
sense um
it frankly puts into context the the
economic uh
challenges of leaving the transition
period on the other hand i think it
ought to focus all of our minds on doing
everything we can
to give the economy a bit of a boost
both on the uk side but also on the
continental european
side um i'm interested as well to um
get a bit of a sense about when the
latest is the deal can be done because
it feels like we've had these deadlines
almost every week on the show we say
it's a crunch week and then actually
everything slips
again when is the latest genuinely what
when is the latest that a deal could be
done
well i'm a bit reticent to give a later
you know an ultimate
uh backstop because the the goal posts
sometimes shift on the eu side but i
think we're into the last
week or so of substantive negotiations
to be honest with you that you do shift
the goal post so but we're
as we've done right the way through
we're there our negotiating team lord
frost david frost
the team done a great job and we're
always there with positive ideas and
positive energy to
see if we can get the deal over the line
uh now
on friday iran's top nuclear scientist
was killed in an ambush
on his car now iran and the president
has blamed israel for the killing and
they've
said the criminal act in their words
would not be left unanswered
how concerned are you about what the
fallout could be
well look we are concerned about the
situation iran and the wider region we
do want to see de-escalation of tensions
and
obviously particularly we want to try
and find a route through on the nuclear
dossier i met with my e3 colleagues so
france and germany
in berlin this week that kind of it's a
good example that kind of cooperation
not
standing on the brexit process keeps
going on we're still waiting to see the
full facts trying to ascertain the full
facts of what's happened
in iran but but i would say that we
stick to the rule of international
humanitarian law which is very clear
against um targeting civilians do you
think israel has got questions to answer
as iran suggests
uh no idea i don't have any of the facts
that would have
enabled me to answer that question at
this point we know of course that
there's been concern over iran's
nuclear programme is the world a safer
place without mosin for cruiser day
look i think that's very difficult to
say because there'll be other scientists
but the reality is what we want to see
and there's an opportunity to look at
the jcpoa again with the dubai
demonstration
but but the truth is the situation we're
in is a series of choices
to go further and further down the track
of non-compliance with its
obligations under the nuclear deal the
jcpoa and we will be
right up till christmas i'll be meeting
with my three colleagues also with iran
if they
are willing to come and attend to make
sure we hold them to account but also to
try and find a peaceful path through
um you mentioned joe biden there um how
different do you expect his
approach to foreign policy will be to
that of its predecessor donald trump
well if every president particularly
come from different parties
has a different set of priorities but my
experience in talking to
leading democrats since uh
president-elect biden and vice
president-elect
harris have been uh declared the winners
uh sir chris coons senator chris [ __ ]
simpson murphy
spoke to nancy pelosi is that there's
huge areas of opportunity so take
climate change
the one thing the new administration
will do is go back into the parents
agreement that's exciting for us we're
hosting cop 26
uh next year they've also said they'll
go back into the who
i spoke to dr ted ross at the who this
week uh talking about all the efforts
we're doing to get not just a vaccine
for the people of this country but
for the world's poorest and most
vulnerable i think in all of those areas
there's real opportunities to work
even more closely together okay uh just
finally while i've got you
there's been a lot of talk of a
reshuffle lots of talk about sadger
javid
becoming the next foreign secretary
you're looking over your shoulder a bit
not really a little bit forgive me i i
don't uh pay too much mind the tittle
tattle about oh come on
if someone's been talked up about taking
your job you've got to be a little bit
yeah
who's doing the talking up but sanji is
a great guy and then since i entered
politics and
look the reality is um prime minister
makes these decisions and i'm working
very effectively with him the chancellor
and everyone else in the cabinet okay uh
thank you uh very much being on the
program dominic ralph nice to see